bei uns hier ist Björn höcke
Landesvorsitzender in Thüringen
Fraktionsvorsitzender der AFD im
türkischen Landtag und viele halten ihn
auch für den heimlichen
Parteivorsitzenden höcke dieser
Bundesparteitag und heute die
europawahlversammlung wird das denn für
sie zur Abschussrampe diese im nächsten
Jahr auf den alleinigen Vorsitz der AFD
katapultieren wird
also diese Frage spielt für mich
tatsächlich im Augenblick noch überhaupt
gar keine Rolle wir haben uns über den
künftigen bundesforscher noch keine
Gedanken gemacht im Augenblick bin ich
sehr zufrieden mit der Arbeit des
Bundesvorstandes stehe auch hinter Tino
cobale und alles Weile wir konzentrieren
uns jetzt auf die Planung der wichtigen
Ost Wahlen in Thüringen und da fließt
all meine Kraft und all meiner den
einmal denken rein und ähm über mehr
möchte ich im Augenblick auch noch gar
nicht Philosophie interessieren hinter
dir aber nicht sich nächstes Jahr auf
dem Partei Tag für den Vorstand für den
für die Parteispitze für den
bundesprecher zu bewerben nein das
sicherlich ist das sind eine Möglichkeit
aber noch mal ich bin sehr glücklich in
Thüringen ich weiß wie wichtig meine
Arbeit auf Landesebene für die
Gesamtpartei ist im Osten kann dass der
Durchbruch gelingen nächstes Jahr und
das ist ein wesentlicher Beitrag zum
Erfolg dieser Partei auf den ich dann
auch stolz sein darf und auch meinen
Anteil bin ich dann stolz zusammen mit
meinem Landesverband das geschafft zu
haben und ob ich dann Bundesvorsitzender
bin oder nicht das ist eine
nachrangige Fragestellung ich bin da wo
die Partei mich brauchen wo ich der
Partei am Besten dienen kann ob sie
nachhaltige Frage ist werden wir dann im
nächsten Jahr sehen zum ganz großen
politischen Erfolg sie haben ja schon
einen fehlen jetzt eigentlich nur noch
ein Bündnis mit Sahra Wagenknecht
ja also es ist ja ein offenes Geheimnis
dass ich durchaus Schnittmengen sehe
hat er glaube schon die AFD Angeboten
genau
ich sehe Durchschnitt Schnittmengen
gerade in der Außenpolitik mit der AFD
und einer alternativen linken ja Sarah
Wagner hat sich da deutlich positioniert
hat deutlich gemacht dieser Krieg ist
nicht unser Krieg äh wir müssen uns aus
der Herr kommunalen und Klammerung der
aus Amerikaner lösen wir müssen einen
eigenen europäischen Weg gehen das kann
ich alles unterschreiben und dieses
Politikfeld ist existenziell deswegen
ist es wichtig damit einer Stimme zu
sprechen aber es gibt natürlich viele
andere Punkte wo wir ein Dissens haben
beispielsweise in der Wirtschaftspolitik
wir könnten ja dann mit der NATO gleich
noch die Europäische Union zum Teufel
jagen zusammen Wagenknecht
ja ich bin kein Freund der Europäischen
Union das ist eine
globalisierungsinstanz und Agentur die
vor allen Dingen den deutschen
Nettozahlern das Geld aus der Tasche
zieht ohne dass wir einen großen Nutzen
davon haben die die vielfältige
europäische Kultur gleich schaltet es
gibt viele gute Gründe jenseits der
Kostengründe diese EU abzulehnen sie
bringt Europa nicht weiter und wenn sie
von mir meine populistische Aussage
hören wollen dann kann ich Ihnen das in
einer Aussage zusammenpacken diese EU
muss sterben damit das wahre Europa
leben kann da bin ich überzeugt ja habe
ich jetzt aber mal eine Lernfrage warum
reden sie eigentlich zur Wahl zum
Europäischen Parlament an wenn Sie das
so schnell wie möglich abschaffen wollen
naja wir sind ja auch gestern zu Europa
Partei beigetreten das heißt wir haben
schon die klare Zielsetzung die EU ist
nicht Reform fähig und muss in einen
neuen europäischen Staatenbund der neu
gegründet wird überführt werden aber das
ist ein organischer Prozess wir sind ja
keine revolutionäre Partei wir sind eine
bürgerliche Partei wir kennen die
Notwendigkeit grundsätzlichere Formen
ein Politik Fällen auch im Bereich der
EU-Politik Europapolitik aber alles mit
Augenmaß und nicht mit heißem Herzen
sondern mit Klugheit und und verstanden
als ein interessanter Hinweis dass sie
die AFD für eine bürgerliche Partei
halten sie haben gerade gesagt wir
müssen uns aus der heckgebundenialen
Umklammerung der USA lösen wir beide
sind Babyboomer aus dem Westen denen der
Marshallplan ein ziemlich komfortables
Leben ermöglicht hat plus Demokratie
plus Rechtsstaat plus Gewaltenteilung
ist das alles nichts mehr wert ja sie
reden jetzt von einem politikprojekt das
schon fast 80 Jahre her ist ich will in
Marshallplan nicht schlecht reden aber
auch das ist natürlich einzuordnen in
den damals auch brechenden Kalten Krieg
auch die Amerikaner hatten damals
imperiale Interessen in Europa natürlich
muss ich auch zugestehen dass man uns
vom Kommunismus geschützt hat das war
auch eine wichtige auftragstellung die
wir gemeinsam hatten und damals war auch
die Gründung der NATO in Ordnung führen
aber die Natur hat sich in den letzten
Jahren immer weniger immer mehr zu einem
offensiv bin ist immer weniger zu einem
Verteidigungsbündnis ausdifferenziert
und das macht uns große Sorgen wir
erkennen dass die NATO vor allen Dingen
in US-amerikanischen Interesse
eingesetzt wird und da braucht es einen
dringend eine Korrektur und da muss
Europa auf eigenen Bein stehen lernen
und das ist ein zentraler Punkt unserer
Forderung gut auf eigenen Beinen stehen
lernen heißt auch unabhängig zu sein in
alle Richtungen ihr Credo ist ja dass
wir von globalistischen Eliten
fremdbestimmt sind so richtig fern
bestimmt waren wir ja eigentlich bis
Februar
2022 durch die nahezu total
Energieabhängigkeit von Russland das hat
sie weniger gestört und jetzt sind wir
abhängig von US-amerikanischen
tracking-gas und von Flüssigkeit aus
Katar ob mich das beruhigt weiß ich
nicht die Russen haben ja auch in Zeiten
ist kein Krieg ist äh das Gas immer
geliefert wir hatten sauberes Gas wir
hatten sicheres Gas und wir hatten vor
allen Dingen kostengünstiges Gas also
dass die Gaslieferung aus dem Osten
jetzt gekappt worden sind durch die
skandalöse Nord Stream ansprengung war
ein wesentlicher Schritt in Richtung
deines Realisierung Deutschlands mit
einem massiven Wohlstandsverlust und ich
glaube die Menschen spüren auch das in
diesem Lande gerade in wirtschaftlichen
Bereich etwas nicht funktioniert und
dass das Geschäftsmodell Deutschland
auch dadurch dass die Energieversorgung
aus dem Osten gekappt worden ist nicht
mehr funktioniert und deswegen brauchen
wir Alternativen ist es noch ganz klar
wir Sprengmeister war in der Ostsee sie
haben gesagt sauberes Gas aus Russland
gewesen gut in jedem Fall führt Russland
einen sehr schmutzigen dreckigen Krieg
in der Ukraine verübt jede Menge
Kriegsverbrechen dort nimmt das die AFD
nicht zur Kenntnis denn das wird hier
eigentlich kaum erwähnt und gibt taucht
auch kaum im Wahlprogramm hier zur
Europawahl auf
also das erste was in einem Krieg stirbt
das ist die Wahrheit das gilt für den
Osten wie für den Westen also seit dem
Kriegsausbruch kann ich auch die
Propaganda in den westlichen Medien kaum
noch von den wirklichen Fakten trennen
ich will die Russen nicht verteidigen
und ich will auch die russische
Propaganda nicht verteidigen noch mal
Deutschland Europa müssen einen
eigenständigen Weg in die Zukunft gehen
aber dieser Krieg hat ein ganz ganz
langen Anlauf der mindestens 30 Jahre
mittlerweile wer hat eine ganz ganz
lange Vorgeschichte mit von außen
initiierten Vater Revolution in der
Ukraine und wenn sie Kriegsverbrechen
ansprechen ja die gibt es leider muss
ich sagen in jedem Krieg und dass die
Amerikaner jetzt Streubomben an die
Ukraine liefern ist in meiner Augen auch
indirekt zumindest ein
kriegsverbrechenden US-Amerikaner
beteiligen auch das kann ich nicht
honorieren es wird mit harten Bandagen
gekämpft das sind Kriege deswegen muss
dieser Krieg zu schnell wie möglich
beendet werden zur kriegsbändigung der
liegt meiner Meinung nach tatsächlichen
[Musik]
zu erwähnen dass sie viel größere Maße
Russland ja schon im Ukraine
kriegstäubomben eingesetzt hat das ist
nicht nur ein Einsatz der USA
wer wird nächster Ministerpräsident von
Thüringen das muss der Thüringer
souverän entscheiden voraussichtlich
haben am 1 September 2024 Landtagswahlen
das noch ein guter Monat ein gutes Jahr
das bis dahin ins Land geht das fließt
noch viel Wasser die Thüringer Flüsse
hinunter
ich sage immer wir kämpfen bis zum
Umfallen und wir wollen mit Abstand
stärkste Kraft werden und als Demokrat
muss man dann irgendwann auch
entscheiden wie weit kann man gehen mit
der Regierung von demokratischen
Prinzipien wenn die AFD wirklich in den
Bereich kommt doppelt so stark zu sein
wie der erste Verfolger in Thüringen
dann darf es keine Frage mehr sein wer
Ministerpräsident wird dann muss das
Spitzenkandidat der AFD werden gut ich
hatte jetzt ja nach einem vor und
Nachnamen gefragt sie könnten ja auch
eine mutige Prognose wagen wieder dann
auch mit Namen heißt dieser
Ministerpräsident
also wenn mich mein Landesverband zum
Spitzenkandidat führen sollte
dann müsste der Name tatsächlich der
meine sein das würde möglicherweise
bedeuten dass alle denkbaren
Koalitionspartner sagen mit dem
garantiert nicht wie gesagt dann tritt
man vielleicht auch den Willen des
Jünger Souveräns mit Füßen und ob das
ratsam ist für die demokratische Kultur
in Deutschland das sage ich zu
bezweifeln ist es gut in
Kanzlerkandidaten oder eine Kandidatin
für die Bundestagswahl aufzustellen
das halte ich für berechtigt ich fand
die die Diskussion um den
Kanzlerkandidaten der AFD auch gut und
richtig wir sind wenn man die CDU die
csu-organisatorisch auseinander
dividiert tatsächlich laut Umfragen gut
Umfang sind Umfang und Wahnsinn Wahlen
im Augenblick stärkste Kraft und wir
sollten in Anspruch haben nicht nur mit
einem Spitzenkandidaten sondern mit
einem Kanzlerkandidaten ins Rennen zu
gehen warum nicht selbstverständlich
soweit Björn höcke im Phoenix Interview
danke für das Gespräch so